[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 tout
de suite les titres de ce mercredi 10
juin 70 collectivités franciliennes au
chevet des entreprises le font résilient
d'île de france a été lancé aujourd'hui
le but de soutenir financièrement la
reprise d'activité des tpe et pme
fortement touché par la crise sanitaire
les détails au début de cette édition
autre conséquence malheureuse de
l'épidémie les soins des personnes
handicapées notamment des enfants ont
été momentanément stoppée 87% de ces
jeunes ont reçu aucune stimulation
pendant le confinement reportage enfin
il s'est aidé confiner le 29 mai dernier
le centre commercial westfield parly ii
accueille de nouveau ses clients pour ce
faire des mesures sanitaires ont été
mises en place sur ce site aux 11
millions de visiteurs par an mais avant
de développer ses titres c'est une
première depuis le 27 mars les
hospitalisations liées aux coronavirus
sont repassés sous la barre des 500 cas
dans les yvelines aux derniers chiffres
publiés hier mardi 4 184 patients
étaient hospitalisés
c 17 en moins par rapport à lundi trente
personnes sont toujours en réanimation
le virus a fait sans cette victime dans
le département soit trois décès
supplémentaires en 24 heures depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire 2006
personnes ont été guéries de lakovic 19
après un passage à l'hôpital je vous le
disais dans les titres la région
ile-de-france et 70 collectivités
franciliennes ont lancé aujourd'hui le
fond résilience cette aide destinée aux
tpe et pme de moins de 20 salariés 100
millions d'euros ainsi débloqués sous
forme de prêt pour permettre la reprise
d'activité économique chez les détails
de nicolas landry
c'est une mobilisation générale de la
part des collectivités pour les
entreprises franciliennes piloté par le
conseil régional le fond résilience va
être abondée par 70 départements
intercommunalités et territoires
d'ile-de-france 100 millions d'euros
dont 25 millions d'euros de la région et
25 millions d'euros de la banque des
territoires je suis heureux et fier de
cette unanimité carré
qui à réunir l'ensemble de ses 70
acteurs des territoires
je pense que c'est une première dans
l'histoire de la région et c'est un tour
de force de l'ensemble de nos équipes
qui ont travaillé d'arrache-pied pour
créer ce consensus est un dispositif qui
me met tous d'accord en seulement
quelques semaines
ce fonds est destiné aux pme et tpe
d'ile-de-france entreprise composée de
moins de 20 salariés sous forme de prêt
à taux zéro les aides varie entre 3000
et 5000 euros avec la possibilité de
rembourser cette avance sur six ans
objectif soutenir la reprise d'activité
de ces sociétés se font il s'adresse à
toutes les entreprises de 0 à 20
salariés qui n'ont plus ou qui n'ont pas
accès au financement bancaire donc c'est
à dire elles ont vu par exemple un refus
de prêt soit totale donc aucun pg aucune
aide soit partiel donc parfois elles ont
eu un prêt redon de la région elles ont
eu un pg e mais pas à hauteur de ce
qu'elle désirait ou d'autres prêts bpi
concernant les intercommunalités un euro
investi permet le financement de 4 euros
dead pour les entreprises du territoire
parmi les contributions dans les
yvelines saint quentin en yvelines va
abonder ce fonds de 500 mille euros
versailles grand parc prévoit une
enveloppe de 360 milles euros
la crise sanitaire qui a donc de lourdes
conséquences économiques ces chiffres
qui nous ont été communiqués par la
préfecture des yvelines en témoigne
également 7846 prêts garantis par l'état
ont été accordés dans le département
pour un montant total de 1,45 milliard
d'euros 65% des entreprises yvelinoise
ont effectué une demande d'activité
partielle ce qui représente à plus de
292 1500 salariés
enfin environ trente mille sociétés ont
bénéficié du fonds de solidarité de mars
à mai pour un montant total de 66,5
millions d'euros cette entreprise s'est
emparé de la thématique des énergies
renouvelables pour se développer basé à
guyancourt elle développe actuellement
un système de flotteurs pour les
éoliennes offshore
son dirigeant a répondu aux questions de
nicolas landry avec nous le pdg de
dietswell jean claude bourdon bonjour
bonjour
dietswell une société implantée à
guyancourt et spécialisée en est un
générique et services de l'industrie des
énergies renouvelables et
conventionnelles vous venez d'être
lauréat de la marine energy alliance
c'est un projet de coopération
territoriale européen et c'est grâce au
développement du concept qu'on voit à
l'image que vous avez obtenu cette
reconnaissance
le trust float la production d'hydrogène
en mer alimenté par une éolienne
flottante
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi consiste ce système royal plaisir
tout d'abord le les projets d'énergie
éolienne offshore sont des sujets dont
on parle depuis longtemps ne met
l'industrialisation un peu tard dès
aujourd'hui les choses se mettre en
place il ya quelques projets pilotes et
surtout il ya deux de grandes ambitions
de de tous les acteurs de des énergies
au sens large et des états qui ont accès
à la mer de récupérer l'énergie éolienne
offshore qui présente beaucoup beaucoup
davantage alors nous on a développé ou
comme vous le savez on vient de
l'industrie pétrolières parapétrolières
notre métier c'était d'exploiter des
plateformes de forage en mer un peu
partout autour de la planète ce qui nous
a permis d'acquérir une longue
expérience et surtout d'avoir énormément
de références cette compétence dans le
domaine offshore condat souhaité mieux
mettre à disposition des indes et des
énergies renouvelables en particulier la
récupération d'énergie éolienne offshore
en développant ce flotteur 3 clos alors
qu'est ce que le fluor trust l'aude
c'est une unité flottante en fait une
grosse bouée composé de trois colonnes
pour la stabilité et semi submersible
c'est à dire qu'elle est ballast et de
manière à la rendre beaucoup plus stable
avec pour objectif de 10 places et en
son centre une éolienne de grosses
capacités
pas moins de six mégawatts ça représente
déjà des unités de grosse taille et plus
probablement dans le futur assez proche
maintenant au delà 10 mégawatts 10 12 15
mégawatts sont envisagées ce qui fera
plus de même des unités qui vont faire
plus de 220 mètres en hauteur vous
imaginez la taille pratiquement la
hauteur nature à faire tout ça offshore
qu'est ce que ça va permettre à ce
système ça va permettre de fournir en
électricité une commune plusieurs
communes
alors évidemment il ya plus faire partir
du moment où fait de l'électricité vous
pouvez en faire presque vous voulez si
vous pouvez la transporter vous pouvez
bien sûr nous l'objectif c'était
éventuellement de la mettre à
disposition d'utilisateurs en mer mais
on peut également en utilisation
secondaire en faire par exemple utiliser
l'électricité pour faire des de
l'hydrogène par exemple hydrogène qui
peut facilement se stocker et
transporter et pourquoi pas pour
utiliser pour être utilisé dans des
véhicules pourquoi pas dans des flottes
de transport urbain comme dans une
commune comme la nôtre par exemple ici
est ce qui pourrait être le cas dans le
futur
après l'électricité peut évidemment être
utilisée est ramené à terre connecté à
la grille mais ça ce sera dans le cadre
de ferme de grosse taille qui feront
plusieurs centaines de mégawatts dont
qui comporteront plusieurs unités comme
le trop ce peloton
on vient de connaître une crise
sanitaire qui a engendré une crise
économique
les gouvernants pense pouvoir relancer
l'économie notamment en investissant
dans l'environnement dans l'énergie dans
les énergies renouvelables pour relancer
aussi une activité l'activité économique
on a vu aussi que l'industrie pétrolière
a été gravement touché un parent par la
crise quel est votre regard justement
sur l'avenir sur l'investissement sur
les énergies renouvelables en tant que
spécialiste de ce sujet alors écoutez
c'est une très bonne question n'avait
lancé le projet retournement des
énergies renouvelables bien avant la
crise du co lead la crise du coc vie
nous a
évidemment renforcée dans cette idée de
faire une transition vers les énergies
renouvelables
la crise du coc vidal yonhap
particulièrement violent effort sur les
industries pétrolières et
parapétrolières à la production la
consommation a baissé d'un minimum de
30% ce qui fait que tous les projets ont
été soit complètement avant et arrêtés
soient reportées au mieux et on voit pas
une reprise forte du secteur avant le
milieu de l'année prochaine au mieux
mais parallèlement les états en
encourage maintenant les la transition
vers la récupération d énergie
renouvelable ce qui aideront dans
l'éolien fait partie et on est très
intéressé de voir ce qui se passe à
l'heure actuelle avec des décisions
fortes d'aider des dirigeants étaient
des états pour investir massivement sur
la récupération de ces énergies
éoliennes en mer merci jean claude
bourdon pdg donc de dietswell société
implantée à guyancourt sur le territoire
de saint quentin en yvelines
je vous remercie beaucoup et un je
souhaite le meilleur à cette industrie
qui est effectivement extrêmement
intéressant porteur d'avenir et
d'emplois pour les jeunes en particulier
merci
[Musique]
j - 18 avant le second tour des
élections municipales c'est le dimanche
28 juin prochain comme chaque soir d'ici
le scrutin présentation des candidats
engagés dans la campagne à plaisir ils
sont trois à se faire face par milieu la
maire sortante joséphine coleman ce
berger arrivé en tête au premier tour
avec la liste plaisir avance nous lui
avons donné deux minutes pour vous
convaincre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon équipe est une équipe jeune motivé
fiable et puis avec une diversité
d'origines socioprofessionnelles et puis
de tous les quartiers de la ville ils
sont engagés pour un projet au service
des plaisirs roi de tous les âges
donc on a une vraie équipe renouvelée à
la fois avec de l'expérience et de la
jeunesse
[Applaudissements]
alors le coiffeur c'est la vie nature et
la ville protectrice
on a pu le constater avec cette période
du cornât virus que les mentalités ont
énormément évolué et changé donc au
niveau de la vie nature c'est quelque
chose que nous avions déjà engagé à
notre niveau dans notre corps notre
présentation de programmes avec un
développement massif des espaces verts
sur la collectivité et la pratique des
vélos les écoquartiers et puis pour
l'aspect protection si surtout la
médecine de proximité avec aussi la
sécurité des citoyens c'est
indispensable
et puis sans oublier l'emploi et le
développement économique puisque
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
véritablement c'est une attente aussi
après cette grande période de crise que
nous avons traversée tous ensemble
[Applaudissements]
l'ouverture de la mise en médical les
médecins nous les avons trouvés ils sont
là donc on va ouvrir cette maison
médicale qui s'appelle la ruche à
l'intérieur de l'hôpital dans un premier
temps avec aussi si vous me le permettez
parce qu'on est quand même dans une
continuité avec un service de navettes
interquartiers pour les seniors et puis
aussi une refonte importante des
tarifications qui sont en cours
actuellement pour accompagner aussi les
difficultés des familles ça me semble
aussi indispensable d'avoir cette
réflexion les directions rambouillet à
présent c'est également une triangulaire
pour ce second tour véronique mathieu
aide de liste de rambouillet ensemble
vers l'avenir s'est classé en première
position le 15 mars dernier présentation
en deux minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on croit fort de la liste c'est une
liste déjà nous avons une partie de la
liste
nous sommes déjà en place dont une
expérience je vous le disais à l'instant
en ce qui me concerne une expérience
d'un mandat de maire adjoint aux écoles
et j'ai pour habitude de dire que
l'école est une bonne école pour savoir
aborder de manière très transversal tous
les problèmes d'une d'une collectivité
et puis sur la liste que j'ai pas mal
renouvelée des nouvelles personnes avec
une grande diversité parce que j'ai
souhaité que cette liste soit sans
étiquette politique
c'est un choix que j'ai fait mon point
fort du programme c'est bah écoutez
c'était avant cette crise sanitaire
c'est la solidarité
une volonté vraiment de remettre à queue
au coeur de notre façon travail et la
solidarité qui a déjà un énorme réseau
sur la ville de rambouillet on a vu
durant la crise à quel point ça a été
important mais continuer à apporter ça
la solidarité la convivialité
[Applaudissements]
alors la première décision ce sera déjà
de travailler à un retour à la vie la
plus normale possible après cette crise
sanitaire
ça va donc être envers les familles pour
qu'elles trouvent l'accueil pour leurs
enfants durant les vacances
et puis ça va être aussi accompagner le
retour à une vie économique pour nos
commerçants artisans toutes les
entreprises en reprenant nos
investissements à ce que les
collectivités territoriales sont
importants dans cette reprise économique
[Applaudissements]
mais dans l'actualité ce retour à la
normale qui n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
la pollution est revenu à un niveau avec
quasi habituel en ce début du mois de
juin dans la région
regardez ces deux cartes qui en
témoignent elles sont similaires à
gauche des conditions habituelles
à droite les observations réalisées dans
la première phase de déconfinement
airparif l'organisme qui mesure la
qualité de l'air en ile de france
indique même que la pollution atteint
80% des seuils habituels du mois de juin
pendant le confinement grâce aux
voitures à l'arrêt les émissions
polluantes avait été divisée par quatre
sur le territoire
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines parmi les 28 meilleures
universités et grandes écoles françaises
résultats du dernier palmarès au world
university rankings de kew est
spécialisée dans l'enseignement
supérieur au niveau mondial du vs qu se
situe même dans le top 1000 d'après le
classement
l établissement est membre pour rappel
de l'université paris saclay dans
laquelle elle fusionnera en 2025
c'est un chiffre édifiant 87 % des
enfants handicapés n'aurait reçu aucun
soin pendant le confinement d'après le
collectif andy actifs france ce constat
est fait également par la plaisir oise
isabelle olivier maman de la petite
anaïs atteinte d'une infirmité motrice
cérébrale depuis sa naissance
manon varaldo a pu suivre leur quotidien
je te donne ta tablette à ressasser le
support que papa fabriqué pour lui
éviter de trop baisser la tête on en
parle peu lors de cette crise sanitaire
les personnes handicapées leurs
difficultés depuis le confinement
isabelle olivier et la mer
d'anaïs 9 ans et demi elle a eu un
accident à la naissance en fait elle
souffre de paralysie cérébrale
elle a eu un manque d'oxygène qui a
provoqué la pas réalisé de ses quatre
membres les jambes les bras et elle a
aussi un problème au niveau de la parole
puisqu'elle a des difficultés à
articuler habituellement entouré d'une
équipe spécialisée anaïs est désormais
toute la journée à la maison depuis ses
deux ans anaïs fait des stages de
rééducation à l'étranger grâce aux dons
récoltés mais avec le coronavirus les
manifestations ont été annulées
les fonds servent aussi pour le matériel
médical nécessaire et les travaux
adaptés pour anaïs ici on lui a fait une
salle de bains une douche à l'italienne
avec des vitres pour que je puisse la
douche et s'en sont même mouillé ça
c'est sa chambre et c'est son lit
médicalisé qu'est la seule chose que
l'on a pu avoir en location anaïs 9 ans
et demi s'intéresse à beaucoup de choses
de son âge mais pour cette mère de
famille c'est une éducation différente
avec beaucoup de frais à sa charge le
fauteuil de douche lui coûtait 1 900
euros et le siège modulable 6000 euros
en fait la mdph nous a remboursé zéro
euro pour récolter des fonds isabelle
olivier a créé l'association analystes
du rêve à l'esport en janvier 2017
elle est investie également dans le
collectif andy actifs france
si on n'avait pas récolté réussi à
récolter tous ces fonds je serais
vraiment enfin complètement déprimé oui
abandonné abandonnés par l'état ça c'est
sûr anaïs on va faire l'orthophonie
d'accord avec le confinement tout est à
distance à l'aide de sa souris de son
clavier adapté cet exercice ludique
permet de pousser anaïs à faire un
maximum de phrases mais sur ok pendant
le confinement toutes les séances de
rééducation d'anaïs ont été arrêtés la
petite fille a perdu en motricité
pendant ces six semaines
c'est vrai qu' on aurait aimé quelqu'un
vienne à domicile pour pour lui donner
des séances mais malheureusement elle
n'en a pas eu les parents d'anaïs ont dû
prendre le relais et ont pratiqué des
séances de tabata par visio l'arrêt des
soins a eu de lourdes conséquences
isabelle olivier a eu plusieurs
casquettes pendant ce confinement mère
de famille professeur éducatrice elle
alerte sur les conditions des aidants ça
demande beaucoup de temps il fallait
aussi en même temps faire à manger faire
le ménage faire les courses
et en plus les
les activités que l'on a l'habitude de
faire en tant qu'aidant anaïs pèse 30 kg
donc elle est assez lourde à manipuler
et là depuis un an je fais des
tendinites chroniques comme vous pouvez
le voir j'ai une ceinture lombaire parce
que j'ai mal au dos donc oui c'est à ça
a été vraiment une épreuve avec le
collectif andy actifs france elles
demandent à l'état que tous les parents
ayant gardé sans relais leur enfant
handicapé pendant le confinement puisse
toucher à eux aussi une prime d'urgence
de 1500 euros que nous vous parlions de
cette opération lancée en avril pour
soutenir le septième art j'aime mon
cinéma a permis est déjà la vente de
près de 400 mille places imaginé par la
société de billetterie posée au
implantée à chambourcy
elle permet d'acheter pour 5 euros une
entrée cette place et à utiliser dans
tous les cinémas qui accepte les chèques
posée au soit 80% des établissements en
france est la durée de validité est fixé
jusqu'au 30 septembre pour permettre un
retour rapide dans les salles obscures
dès le 22 juin date pour rappel un
autorisé de la réouverture des cinémas
c'est l'un des plus grands centres
commerciaux de l'ouest parisien en
termes de superficie parler d'eux a été
autorisée à rouvrir le 28 mai dernier
suite à une décision du tribunal
administratif de versailles pour ce
faire le site qui accueille 11 millions
de personnes par an a dû repenser son
parcours elle mettre en place des
mesures sanitaires pour faire respecter
la distanciation physique
le reportage de michael et demi d'euros
gel hydroalcoolique sens de circulation
nouvelle signalisation sol port du
masque recommandé le centre-ouest fils
de parly 2 fermée depuis mars a rouvert
ses portes le 29 mai dernier en mettant
en place des mesures sanitaires pour
lutter contre le coc u19 une
réorganisation inédite pour répondre aux
demandes des autorités
tout est clair et chaque boutique a pris
ses dispositions le centre aussi donc
non ce en toute sécurité
ça nous change un peu nos habitudes
au moins pu faire se rentrent dedans
c'est très bien vu les circonstances en
ce moment c'est parfait c'est parfait on
a des sens j'ai de la sécurité non c'est
bien je pense que tout le tout le monde
s'est adapté à cette situation et à
cette crise qu'elle on doit s'adapter
faire preuve d'agilité et je pense que
les visiteurs sont d'abord très content
de revenir à oui s'il parlait d'eux et
ils prennent eux mêmes déjà leurs
précautions en venant donc c'est une si
bonne nouvelle dans le centre la
quasi-totalité des boutiques ont rouvert
progressivement 175 en scène sur 183
accueille aujourd'hui les clients les
habitudes des consommateurs ont quant à
elles évolué depuis leur retour en
attaque on a beaucoup moins de
promeneurs dans le domicile par l'idée
aujourd'hui en revanche voilà quand ils
viennent ce qu'on a c'est que ils
viennent pour acheter et de ce que nos
enseignes nous disent depuis la
réouverture vendredi dernier c'est que
le taux de transformation est très bon
et les paniers moyens sont sont plus
élevés que d'habitude
le centre espère maintenant une
réouverture du cinéma le 22 juin
prochain toujours en respectant les
règles sanitaires
enfin ce rendez vous à noter dans vos
agendas ce samedi c'est la deuxième
édition des rendez vous de la
briqueterie décoration textile arts
graphiques ou encore couture cette
pépinière d'entreprises installées à
feucherolles mettra en avant près de 25
stands d'artistes et de créateurs à
l'occasion de découvrir des savoir faire
locaux un événement qui aura lieu en
plein air de 10h à 19h tout en
respectant bien sûr les règles
sanitaires
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi retour de l'information
locale dès demain même heure très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]